Let's Travel back to the Epic era of
frosted tips low-rise jeans Myspace and
velor tracksuits when people think back
on 2000's fashion the first thing
they're going to think about is Juicy
Couture I've never stopped wearing it
honestly though why did we do that but
these were some very important times for
a lot of us folks you probably got your
first flip phone lightly in hot pink you
raced home every night to see who
messaged you on MSN and you re-watched
the Brittany Madonna and Christina VMA
kiss with your newly broadband internet
on repeat ah yes good times as an 80s
babe and a 90s kid the 2000s were my
true formative years and For Better or
Worse the movies made me who I am today
not sure what that's saying about me
considering this was the time of The
House Bunny
but whatever
we're talking Classics here so crimp
your hair get on your corset and belt
out that Lady Marmalade because today
we're going to be making a day of eats
inspired by my favorite 2000s movies hey
guys it's your favorite Elder Millennial
and dietitian welcome to Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
a quick disclaimer that the meals I make
in this video are not a suggestion for
how you should eat these aren't
necessarily what I eat in a day I simply
am using inspiration from my favorite
iconic 2000s movies to build out a day
of balanced eating Abbey style also if
you're new here don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
Bell so you never miss out on an episode
let me hop in here super quick to talk
about my sponsor element as I'm getting
older I've realized how much better I
feel when I'm properly hydrated and yes
this obviously means focusing on
drinking a lot of water every day but
this also means ensuring I'm
replenishing electrolytes too and
anytime I speak with any of my Rd
colleagues about electrolyte supplements
we are all in agreement that element is
our go-to so element is an electrolyte
drink mix with no sugar gluten colors or
artificial ingredients added containing
an evidence-based electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligram sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 milligrams magnesium I
spent a few months in Florida this year
and I played tennis in the heat a few
days a week and if I didn't have my
element afterwards I kind of felt off
all day ensuring I'm keeping on top of
my fluid and electrolyte needs helps to
regulate hormones nutrient absorption
and fluid balance to reduce the risk of
headaches muscle cramps and fatigue and
it's not just for exercising heavily
outdoors I depended on these things
while I was breastfeeding and if I drink
I always have an electrolyte drink
before bed and even if you're not doing
any extracurriculars some folks are just
kind of salty sweaters and may need a
little more electrolytes to feel their
best my favorite is the watermelon and
when I'm craving something a little
spicy the mango chili totally hits right
now element is offering my viewers a
free sample pack with any order so you
get eight single serving packets free
with any element order this is an ideal
way to try all eight flavors or share
element with a salty friend so you can
get yours at drinkelement.com Abby sharp
and this is only available if you use my
link so again go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t.com slash ABI sharp to
get yours today all right Abby let's see
oh the two thousands
they were rough let's just say that
especially for women in diet culture and
to help me get into character today I
even went to my mom's house busted out
the old photo albums and found some not
so cute images guys there's an
obligatory shot of me sleeping with my
teddy I mean like was this one that all
teenage girls did we had to take photos
of ourselves pretending to sleep Ella
Britney Spears Rolling Stone slumber
party and seen that the trend hasn't
died because most influencers still do
this with their Day in the Life Vlogs
let me tell you right now folks if an
influencer is showing themselves getting
out of bed they had to get out of bed
and position the camera there to
enough embarrassing Nostalgia for today
I need my coffee and we cannot talk
about the 2000s without paying homage to
the cult classic mean girls I know this
movie by heart so of course I know
Regina George's iconic coffee order you
think I'm an idiot no she doesn't even
go here I just have a lot of feelings
yeah I have like ESPN my nipples know
when it's gonna rain well they know when
it is raining that was so fetch on
Wednesdays we were pink that's why her
hair is so big it's full of secrets if
you're from Africa why are you white oh
my God Karen you can't just ask people
whether white we go to Taco Bell oh
Karen I can't go to Taco Bell I'm on an
all-carb diet gosh you're so stupid
raise your hand if you've ever been
personally victimized by Regina George
in case you're wondering butter is not a
carb nor is the cream that we're about
to put in our latte and in typical 2000s
fashion I am pretty sure that Regina
George would go for like the fat-free
milk and then add the cream to it
because the diet culture messaging in
that movie is nothing if not incredibly
ironic
ugh that looks terrible I
have cream in my latte
latte seeing like the keto thing to do
speaking of stupid diet Trends Abby can
you like go over the whole low carb
versus high carb low fat high fat if
Regina George did want to lose weight
what would be her best bet
well to start I don't recommend
consuming an all fat or all carb diet I
can't go to Taco Bell I'm on an all-carb
diet God Karen you are so stupid it has
been long debated on what is better for
weight loss low fat or low carb and the
answer is not so black and white
research does suggest that low-carb
diets tend to be more effective in the
short term for weight loss likely
because of its appetite suppressing
capabilities and the initial drop in
water weight when we deplete our
glycogen stores but water weight isn't
fat and therefore when we look at the
data long term we don't actually see any
major differences when it comes to
weight loss in other words weight loss
comes down to what is the most
sustainable and enjoyable way for you to
create a calorie deficit oh sorry I was
listening Abby I just happened to find a
BuzzFeed quiz called your Starbucks
drinks will determine which Mean Girls
plastic you are and I think we need to
play okay do you want a hot drink or a
cold drink
about what kind of drink do you want tea
frappuccino coffee hot chocolate oh I'm
a coffee girl pick a flavor vanilla
caramel mocha matcha caramel obviously
boink pick a size tall Grande venti
Trenta Trenta that's extra I'm just
going classic Grande because I'm default
pick a snack Bagel brownie croissant
granola oh I mean I don't like the
croissants at Starbucks so we're going
brownie oh and Karen Karen Smith I'm
friendly hilarious and loving obviously
well that was fun let's make some
breakfast
okay I have a very 2000s question for
you when you hear this song are you
thinking Napoleon Dynamite or Center
Stage this is gonna like separate the
dancers from the non-dancers I legit
went back to ballet school with like
five-year-olds when I was in high school
because I was so inspired by that film
but yeah I actually love both movies
dearly and there wasn't a whole lot of
eating in Center Stage for being totally
honest it is a little triggering we'll
say that but Napoleon Dynamite has some
dang good food references well what's
there to eat
knock it off Napoleon make yourself a
dang quesadilla
fine
I have never met a single human who
doesn't love a quesadilla and
quesadillas for breakfast get at me at
me to you you fat Lord come get some
dinner girls only want boyfriends with
great skills kid bring me my Chapstick
gosh gosh gosh are you taking one
percent because you think you're fat
because you're not you could drink hole
if you wanted Napoleon give me some of
your thoughts no go find your own okay
we're gonna do a little breakfast
quesadilla
and it starts with some eggs and loads
of cheese
and I'm gonna add some bell pepper into
mine for some color I swear to God all
my friends and I like did our own Glamor
Shots just like that after Napoleon came
out this is looking really good you can
say that again
all right I'm kind of just freestyle on
this it's been a while since I've made a
egg quesadilla
this is a very stressful moment
okay not bad not bad not bad not bad
all right we gotta cut this
all right folks let's recap we have
protein in our eggs plus our Cheese
healthy fats in the guac lots of high
fiber carbs in our tortillas and in a
little bit of veg plus our avocado I am
going to just do mine up like this okay
what
little salsa action
that is so good I'm gonna do this like
way more often
all right since we're on a Napoleon
Dynamite kick I feel like we can get a
little workout in here with a dance
number now it's been about 20 years
since I've watched slash done this dance
I was part of a traveling theater group
in high school where we used to go to
different schools and entertain them
with our
with our exceptional theater talent and
uh we did a little dance to this at some
point and once I re-watched the clips
I've realized how horrible it was yeah
we somehow thought we were just like
killing it but let's do this
stop it
that's enough it is lunch time and I'm
feeling royally nostalgic and I feel
like we need a little rom-com interlude
to like feel some feels The Princess
Diaries is one of the best feel good
movies if you're having a hard day I
need a little positive affirmation
listen up I got you no one can quit
being who they really are wow is having
the power to affect change you saw me
when I was invisible no one can make you
feel inferior without your consent
you've been hurt so you just cry okay
ask me I'll need a good cry
so now that we're all feeling more
confident strong and hungry let's take a
look at this lunch I didn't order pizza
I'm sorry no no you must that's our
motto
you don't make the pizza no no I just
deliver them
[Music]
Pizza though I can totally get on board
with a little chocolate m m action on
the side
I am all for any reason to have pizza
for lunch so I'm going to show you how I
transform a basic frozen pizza into a
balanced meal frozen pizza damn I'm
gonna add some spinach literally just
like any leftover vegetables that I have
weren't weren't some chicken
or some protein I've got some broccoli
that I've just got left over in the
house so I can add that on some bell
peppers some more color more fiber and
some tomatoes and I acknowledge that
there's already cheese on this pizza but
now that I've added more toppings I feel
like we should put some more cheese on
top so let me get that
she she's
pleased and this adds more protein and
some calcium as well so we love to see
it pizza time
it's Pizza Time and she's extra cheesy
nice
all right I lift this up so I've got
some pine nuts on top for some healthy
fats delish
oh
add the five hours later
me five hours later yes
I'm pumped now honestly a little hot
honey just takes a pizza up to the next
level okay tell me this meal does not
look amazing but also let this be a
reminder
[Applause]
crust double cheese double pepperoni is
gonna do and you can serve with a side
salad or some veggies on the side if you
don't want to load it up on your pizza
or maybe you just don't not every meal
needs to be perfectly balanced or a
hunger crushing combo also can we just
acknowledge that wearing these like
little pieces in front of our face like
we used to do in the early 2000s is
really annoying it's like bangs but with
slightly more options so take a look at
this bad boy oh the honey though guys
I'm telling you we didn't have hot honey
in the 2000s but if we did I would have
been all over that
um this is so good so far on this little
nostalgic blast from the past we have
nailed the comedy genres but I feel like
it's time for a little ugly cry look no
further than our generation's poster
child of body and security Bridget Jones
this movie is a true sign of the times
and can definitely be seen as a
commentary on diet culture in the 2000s
in the books and movies Bridget is often
shown kind of cycling through different
diets and exercise regimens often
resulting in her hating her body and
herself even more every single time they
fail I mean this is a heavy topic so
before I even get into the food Abby can
you go over what dye culture looked like
in this defining decade oi the 2000s
were unkind for so many reasons and I'm
sure a lot of you watching can attest
the persistent damage that this decade
has done this was when the biggest loser
and other thinspiration weight loss
related reality TV were really in their
Prime like these are shows that promoted
and celebrated disorderly behaviors and
resulted in scientifically proven
long-term damage for contestants this
was also the era of mass body shaming
and criticism in the media celebrities
were either being ripped apart for being
too fat or too thin with non-stop
commentary that surely only served
perpetuate any unhealthy problematic
behaviors but let's talk about some of
the Heavy Hitters of this area this was
also a time when low carb diets reign
supreme the Atkins and South Beach diets
were really popular in the early 2000s
which kind of then opened the door for
more extreme versions like keto a decade
later celebrities and their weight loss
campaigns also ran rampant Oprah and
Jessica Simpson rep weight watchers
Marie Osborne use Nutrisystem Christie
alley on her Jenny Craig and Whoopi
Goldberg used Slim Fast let's not forget
about the inspiration blogs this is the
birthplace of dangerous Pro Ed
inspiration blogs Tumblr and Reddit
threads these accounts often shared
images of emaciated models and
celebrities as well as tips for
restrictive diets and excessive exercise
and I do definitely fear that this trend
is making a dreaded Resurgence in 2023
and finally the skinny fashion I
discussed this in my video on Y2K
fashion trends resurfacing right here
but the early 2000s look can be
described as nothing else but basically
malnourished this trend led to concerns
about the health and well-being of
models as well as criticism of the
fashion industry for promoting an
unhealthy body image so let's be real
not surprisingly not much has changed
thank you so much Abby I appreciate the
thoroughness I was actually just
procrastinating because for dinner we
are making blue soup yep you heard me
right blue soup I'm sure you're all
thinking Abby why can't we just have
chicken noodle or minestrone and say I
like you very much just as you are
but we are trying to channel the iconic
Bridget Jones's energy here which means
we have to put ourselves in
uncomfortable situations and try new
things okay so according to this online
recipe this is basically just like a
simple potato soup with some food diet
um but I've got some tricks up my sleeve
to make it a little more nutritious and
balanced and hopefully a lot less gross
all right olive oil down
and we're gonna do some onion
all right celery parsnips because
they're like a white carrot but I think
they are even more tasty so I'm gonna
add Lots we got our potatoes
and I'm gonna add some cauliflower for
some extra fiber the thing about soups
and me is we just completely freestyle I
never follow a recipe for a soup and it
always just works out beautifully that
said I've never made blue soup so this
might be my first epic fail all right
I'm gonna add in some bouillon
[Music]
pop lid on and let it do its thing okay
so this is my little hat when you want a
creamy soup without having to add cream
plus a little extra fiber and protein
for good measure I'm adding a can of
white beans when you puree it it gets
super thick super creamy and we're
adding lots of nutrition as well so this
can become like a full hearty meal so in
Bridget style she did struggle a bit
with the blending situation
so
we're prepared
looks nice and creamy a little salt a
little pepper I should use white pepper
but I don't have it
okay last little
now I'm using a spirulina based natural
food dye just because I personally am
sensitive to a lot of artificial food
dyes but while I work that in Abby can
you give us like the rundown on
spirulina is it actually worth the hype
on it spirulina is an algae-based
supplement that grows in fresh and salt
water and is rich in antioxidants and
protein researchers found that it may be
effective in clinical doses for reducing
blood sugar cholesterol allergic
rhinitis blood pressure and improving
athletic performance now of course a
drop of concentrated spirulina-based
food dye isn't going to magically make
you like Magic Johnson but it does make
food a little more fun for kids and kids
at heart the blue is throwing me guys
it's throwing me hard because I wouldn't
want to offend her at her dinner party
either
if you close your eyes it's delicious
and it's also pretty nutrient packed
poppy okay you had pizza you had pizza
you give an inch she takes a mile
honestly we got fiber rich carbs in our
potatoes our vegetables our bread trust
me you don't want it don't even smell it
you don't want it we've got protein in
our white beans and some healthy fats in
the pine nuts that I threw on top it's
actually delicious even though it kind
of looks like blue milk from Star Wars
and it may turn my tongue blue not that
it'd be the first time
evidence
oh the shorts were so short so I'm going
to finish this off probably with my eyes
closed and I'll meet you back here for
dessert brought to you by L Woods
as you may or may not know Elle Woods
and her dog Bruiser are both Gemini
vegetarians and they also invented the
iconic abandoned snap so you been
and snap
see
like most of us ladies our friend Elle
you are being so
sassy today okay I know we're talking
about another dog right now but like
chill anyways what I was saying is that
like most of us girlies L Woods needs a
little some sweet in some challenging
times if we swap out the Heartbreak for
like pure motherhood exhaustion and
General Hospital For Love is Blind you
basically have me right here right now
and I can always get on board with
little chocolate something something so
this is one of our favorite little
desserts in my house we're gonna make my
no bake chickpea chocolate chip cookie
dough balls we gotta Workshop the title
but it's delicious let's do it okay
chickpeas down
drained rinsed you gotta go with the no
salt added otherwise these are kind of
like sweet but also like Savory you need
about a quarter cup of peanut butter
just gonna eyeball
a couple tablespoons of Honey or maple
syrup yield choice if you want to keep
it fully vegan a little splash of you
know what mentally
some almond flour you could also use oat
flour but I like the healthy fats in
almond flour this is just kind of like
gonna glue it all together I know I just
said we don't want to make them too
salty but you need like a little salt to
bring out the delicious flavor in
chocolate in my honest opinion let's
blend
I'm adding some chocolate chips right to
the mix but don't worry there'll be some
more chocolate action in a minute
this is a
generous ball size
well this will be a nice vacation for
his balls we're gonna pop this in the
freezer for like 10 minutes
a little jargon in everyday life
I don't need backups I'm going to
Harvard whoever said Orange Is the New
Pink was seriously Disturbed oh I like
your outfit too but when I dress up as a
frigid I try not to look so
constipated
when used appropriately it has an 83
return on a dinner invitation it's
called the bend and snap God help my
titties
oh that is a chocolate ball I want to
eat mom win
we're gonna do a little salt on top
maybe a little sprinkle action for
funsies how fun are these like huge
upgrade from a Starbucks cake pop which
costs like way too much money for what
they're worth so to recap we have lots
of fiber in our chickpeas plus healthy
fats in the almond flour and the peanut
butter and tons of fiber in there from
the beans as well and lots of chocolate
for good measure
mmm soften the inside crunchy on the
outside I'm telling you these just hit I
don't know what I'm more impressed with
my little baby cake pops or the fact
that I got through this entire video
dressed like JLo and didn't have an epic
Janet Jackson nip slip I mean I guess
we'll find out in the editing process
how successful we actually were
this date was so much fun I got to
channel my inner teenager I got to
re-watch some of my favorite movies of
all time and I got chocolate love it so
guys if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up let me know in the
comments what 2000s movies and food
scenes I missed and if there's another
decade or another theme you guys want me
to cover leave me a comment below and
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
guys if you are new here and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye bye